hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge happy
ich habe mir gedacht das spiel kamen so
lange nicht mehr und ist locker schon
ein halbes jahr her deswegen befinden
wir uns gerade im happy meals menü ich
klicke einfach mal ob broß levels weil
ich habe schon aufleveln dem contractor
gedrückt weil wir heute ein kraft das
game zocken werden ja ich habe übrigens
gerade einmal eine cap auf ich weiß ich
trage sehr selten caps und ich habe die
auch falsch rum auf und ich glaube ich
habe noch nie ein video mit einer kerb
gemacht wo ich die so rum auf hatte ich
weiß ist die kacke aus allerdings waren
wir heute den ganzen tag am drehen für
einen riesen amazon projekt und es war
voll in der sonne und meine haare ist
einfach nur krank am arsch und ich habe
sonnenbrand und ich zeige euch einen
kleinen ausschnitt aus der sache die wir
gedreht haben
ich muss dazu sagen ich sollte
eigentlich mit weg laufen aber ich habe
es total verpeilt und bin als jetzt
laufen guckt einfach selbst ich werde
nicht dafür bezahlt dass ich diesen
ausschnitt gezeigt habe ich fand es
witzig weil ich hab ein kumpel mein
handy haben wir drücken ihr film dass
man das ist gerade probe und ich habe es
total verkackt einfach nicht witzig wir
haben hier sehr viele levels die alle
auf kuba sogar 2016 wurden schon welche
gemacht alter wie wieso macht den levels
ich hab's doch ein halbes nicht mehr
hochgeladen wir spielen einfach mal das
neueste apple hier und nehmen als
charakter mal den ganz normalen er gut
ich hab jetzt eine oper norma und europa
you can't do der meine ich habe ja
das ist seine wirbelsäule wir machen das
jetzt einfach mal dass du ja schon unten
hier fahren hier weiter geradeaus schön
gegen die anderen obst kommt dk was was
macht er denn kopien 1 ist auf seinem
blöden ding ausgeschieden ich will doch
nur ganz locker und sagte mit dem opa
die treppen runter so und jetzt ganz
locker und sagte über die alle drüber
und hier lang und jetzt haben wir ich
bin gerade in so ein geheimtipp gegangen
clique die jetzt alle hier und spiele so
brutal wecken slater ich habe gerade
ganz kurz gewartet einfach damit ich im
schnitt weiß dass ich jetzt ein paar
sätze und die teile fliegen immer noch
wirklich die luft und über alles blut
jägerheim weg den ich entdeckt habt
befindet sich nämlich genau hier da
müssen wir nämlich durch und jetzt
europa kommt es ist doch nicht so schwer
einfach da diese blöde kaffee sei und
jetzt jetzt richtig lampen und jetzt
wieder weiter und opa dann sind wir auch
jetzt jeden moment
du liegst auf einem haushalt er ahnt
nicht wie schwierig es ist mit diesem
opa diese blöde scheiße hier hoch zu
kommen weil der sich die ganze zeit
irgendwelche anderen um eine seit 1
und mit dem kopf doch die can do drk
sammelt das war nur eins wir spielen
jetzt mal das level kong crafter kurz
hallo dieses mein erstes ich bin happy
denn ich hoffe du hast spaß
du warst ein ich konnte die mal lesen
was versteht von crafter hat über eine
million abonnenten oder 100.000
abonnenten es ist beides richtig ich
habe über eine million und über ein oder
zu hause über eine millionen da gehen
wir hier durch das das ist bitte
erstelle nie wieder ein level die fragen
sind blöd und ich hänge in dieser kacke
hier drin und kommen hier nicht mehr
raus dieses level hat tatsächlich
irgendwie schon 5000 place und zwar
erstmal das weib loswerden mit l shift
unten kann ich die frau es nicht
irgendwie nach dahinter ist klar ich
fahre hier lang nach vorne und ich liebe
eure levels alter ich nehme die frau
jetzt einfach alles klar wir fahren hier
vorne lang und gwb war warum warum war
wie soll es klappen ich werde jetzt
erstmal die frau ich mir noch alles
wieder zu blöd hier habt ihr nicht mal
irgend welche levels gemacht die
wirklichen eis sind das erste level was
je in diesem spiel für mich gemacht
wurde ist vom dritten ach oder 83 auf
jeden fall aus dem jahr 2012 und das
spielen wir jetzt diese seite toll was
wir durchgemacht haben mit dem fahrrad
man fahrrad man wieso nennst du ihn
fahrrad man kann man über so was drüber
fahren war über es ist den pussy brno
und ich war über und das ich
ich kann tatsächlich das ist dieses
level ist ich bin ich kann die ganze
zeit einfach geradeaus fahren
tatsächlich und jetzt ich glaub ich bin
so ca der schlechteste radfahrer der
welt weil dann werd ich bin dein sohn
dazu kommt ok ver weiter nur noch ein
bisschen würde der nächste tipp wenn du
mit dem fahrrad helm ganz schnell
hintereinander abwechslung auf dem
steuerrecht nach links drücken zu
fliegen
nächstes level immer nicht des ultra 30
levels macht aber vielleicht sollten sie
klappen
abwehrmann an oder vielleicht sollte ich
besser sein in dem spiel dieses level
hat 3600 place und viereinhalb sterne
hey ho community ich habe diesen selbst
schon mal für den guten seiten fall
hochgradig sagte mir warum ich auch
bekommen viel spaß teilen sie mir geht's
gut ich war ich fahre ohne beinen okay
ich war doch noch mit meiner wenn man
beim tritt irgendwie tatsächlich ohne
dass ich irgendwie das nicht aber meine
breche dgaki laufe man meinen da macht
dasselbe tatsächlich hat noch weiter
dass sie tatsächlich sehr falsch aus
dass er gerade da jetzt habe ich
tatsächlich auch ein bein verloren
ich weiß nicht nicht gerade gas geben
kann aber irgendwie schaffe ich es ja
und jetzt ist meine hose wieder bei
meinem bein kann der check steckt in der
hose irgendwie drin ich versuche jetzt
mal nicht immer diese mine sondern
einfach da drüber haben dort jetzt hat
er ich habe zumindest auch alle
körperteile und jetzt auch ab über das
glas hier drüber und jetzt die den
wrecking ball krieg ich mitten aber über
die brücke drüber und den wrecking ball
schön abwarten bis er hinter mir ist und
schnell habe wie soll es klappen kann
ihr könnt noch immer auf maut netz.de
gegenwart ich schreib sich kurz auch ihr
könnt noch immer auf scoach.de gehen
da gibt es noch ein paar klamotten die
noch restbestand sind von
der kollektion so sieht das aus nicht
artikulieren und auswahl dieses material
an
das ist noch ein paar sachen im shop und
die sind wahrscheinlich schnell weg
wieder deswegen wenn ihr was bestellt
man sich am besten schnell ich packe ich
den link nicht in die beschreibung weil
das ist jetzt quasi nur für die leute
die das jetzt wissen die so lange dran
geblieben sind also bitteschön
oh mein gott werdet sehen sollen wie ich
den stoff grad da rein geworfen hat da
vorne ist meine schublade für
schreibwaren und jarmen aufnahme zimmer
ist quasi in meinem kleiderschrank ich
bin kein youtuber mit 10 milliarden euro
und hab ja ich hab den einfach so nach
hinten geworfen und jetzt einfach so
reingerutscht gegen die scheibe und da
rein und das war dann damit würde ich
sagen wenn dich das heutige wie die fans
ganze total verhalten hiermit beende ich
das heutige video wenn es euch gefallen
natürlich meine bewertung freuen wollt
ihr mehr happy meals dann macht mir
levels oder so und geht auf monster.de
solange die sache noch da sind und dann
sehen wir uns im nächsten video wieder
auf 1